Remoras, nature’s underwater hitchhikers, hold on tight
to jumping dolphins, boat hulls, even divers.
Also called suckerfish, their amazing grip
comes from an adhesive disk made from a modified
dorsal fin on the fish’s head.
So obviously, the question is--
could a robot be designed hold on this tight,
underwater, to different surfaces?
Making something that works like a remora’s disk
will help us better understand how they work
and could one day lead to useful underwater
devices
based on the same principles.
Researchers took up the challenge and designed
a “biomimetic remora disk”
Like the fish’s specialized sucker,
it can make a seal and has rows of flaps,
dotted with tiny spikes,
that allow it to raise and lower the area under the seal.
To test out how well this sucker worked,
researchers attached it to
a remote controlled controlled submarine,
and tested out its capabilities.
On average, the sucker grabbed onto
plexiglass and sharkskin in less than four seconds,
and held on tight.
Once stuck, It took 45 kilograms of force to remove it.
That’s about 340 times the weight
of the prototype sucker.
It also stayed sticky outside of the water as well
In the future, researchers hope to see
similar suction systems used anywhere
strong adhesion is needed
and at some point used to extend
the range of robotic submarines.